hey 42 here we've all woken up after a
house party with a pounding head and
dressing our stomachs as we ponder that
age-old question just what the hell
happened last night
but no matter how hard you may have
partied over the years I'm willing to
wager you've never woken up with a dead
moose at the bottom of your stairs
that's what happened to a Danish
nobleman after the mother of all parties
Inland scrawna Castle towards the tail
end of the 16th century to make matters
worse it wasn't even his moose the Beast
belonged to the nobleman's friend a man
named Tico brahe who coincidentally was
one of the most important people in
Denmark
if you're wondering why Tico had a pet
moose in the first place well that's
just kind of how he rolled in fact his
entire life reads like a badly written
fantasy novel seriously you couldn't
make this stuff up as a child he was
kidnapped by a member of his own family
he lost his nose in a jewel with a
different member of his family and if
rumors are to be believed he had an
affair with the queen of Denmark for
this and other reasons he was eventually
exiled and a few years later he either
died of extreme politeness or was
murdered depending on which historian
you choose to believe oh and as well as
a pet moose he also owned a dwarf with
magical powers and an entire Island that
in the 16th century was briefly one of
the most important places on Earth
that's a pretty crazy life right there
and I haven't even told you what he was
actually famous for yet because Tico
brahe also happens to have been one of
the most influential scientists in
history a man who despite his reputation
for living life to the max somehow
managed to find the time to
revolutionize astronomy and play Yoda to
one of History's Greatest Luke's science
Walkers Johannes Kepler this is the
truly bunker story of Tico brahe The
Eccentric genius you've probably never
heard of
are your neurons sweating trying to
juggle countless passwords and payment
details for your business well with
nordpass business password manager you
can save time and energy allowing your
team to focus on what matters most
because nordpass business is your time
saving productivity boosting digital
wingman Gunner the days of forgotten
passwords and scrambled account
recoveries all your company's digital
keys are stored in here ready to unlock
the internet at the flick of your finger
with node pass you can log in from
anywhere faster than you can say forgot
password its autofill feature is like a
digital Butler popping your usernames
and passwords into login Fields exactly
when you need them also Phil works with
your payment information too you can pay
for orders ads and invoices in just a
few seconds communicating sensitive data
by instant messaging or email is not
only a security liability but it's a
Time waster often kicking off lengthy
response chains to confirm receipts but
nor pass confidential information can be
saved securely in just one place and
accessed and updated by all others in
your business when you need it and just
when you think it couldn't get any
better nordpass is also your personal
data Guardian it scans the dark corners
of the web 24 7 for data breaches and
this will notify you in real time so
click the link in the description and
use my Code 42 to see nordpass business
in action right now with a three-month
free trial don't miss out and a big
thanks to nordpass for sponsoring this
video
Tico was born in not stop Castle in 1546
in what was at the time Denmark and is
now Sweden like Ron Burgundy the brahays
were kind of a big deal all of Tico's
immediate male ancestors served the
Danish King as members of the privy
Council and his mother was Chief lady in
waiting to the queen
but for all their Pomp and Circumstance
de bruh Hayes were an odd bunch at a
mere two years of age Tico was abducted
by his own Uncle who unable to have
children of his own was in the market
for an heir and rather than you know
getting their son back after a bit of
grumbling Tico's parents apparently
accepted this bizarre development and
from then on the young type was raised
by his uncle in a series of fancy
castles receiving an extensive education
befitting his Noble birth at 12 he was
packed off to Copenhagen University
fulfilling his father's or brother
uncles Ambitions by studying law two
years later he witnessed a Celestial
spectacle that would alter both his life
and the history of modern science
the solar eclipse of 1560 was one of the
first in modern times to be relatively
accurately predicted it's something we
take for granted these days but to Tico
the ability to foresee such an
awe-inspiring event was akin to Magic
and as the moon's silhouette glided
gracefully across the Sun casting its
shadow he decided to spend the rest of
his life trying to become the magician
[Music]
for Millennia before Tico's time mankind
had been mapping the stars and extensive
astronomical tables detailing their
positions and trajectories already
existed
yet the more TECO gazed at the night sky
the more he realized something strange
these tables are all bloody useless full
of inaccuracies just waiting to be
corrected
like most students Tico enjoyed a drink
and during one particularly boozy party
he got into an argument with his third
cousin this wasn't your typical booze
boosted bickering about girls or who won
the drinking game these two Danish
dandies couldn't agree on who was the
better mathematician
so how did they settle this highbrow
drunken debate did they compare grades
or have a good old-fashioned maths off
nah they tried to kill each other but
being 16th century Danish Nobles they
issued their standard issue fist
swinging scuffle and stepped outside for
a formal Jewel
there's no record of who won but seeing
as Tico went home that night with half
his nose missing I'm going to assume it
wasn't him
he wore a prosthetic for the rest of his
life something that's clearly visible in
his portraits
for a long time historians fought this
substitute snars was made of gold and
silver alloy but when Tico's remains
were exhumed in 2010 chemical analysis
revealed it to be brass
after leaving University Tico fell in
love never one for convention his heart
yearned not for a princess or prominent
lady but quite the opposite she was a
commoner even today marriage is outside
of Social Circles are somewhat uncommon
but since 16th century Denmark they were
practically unheard of such a union was
so frowned upon that had Tico actually
married his lowborn boo he would have
been stripped of his rights as a noble
like meatloaf he would do anything for
love but he wouldn't do that luckily he
didn't have to because Danish law at the
time permitted something called Morgan
attic marriage if the couple lived
together for three years their
partnership would automatically become
legally binding but crucially if Tico
was to die first his low-born wife
wouldn't inherit his estate it was a
16th century prenup ice
by 1572 Tico had quietly transformed
himself into one of the most
accomplished astronomers on Earth
after years of painstaking observations
he knew the night sky better than anyone
else alive thus he was perfectly placed
to spot a sudden Celestial change
when a brand new star appeared in the
constellation Cassiopeia to say that's a
new star in the night sky was unexpected
would be the understatement of the 16th
century because until now Humanity had
believed the Stars to be immutable
for that reason most of Tico's
contemporaries dismissed this Celestial
interloper as some kind of atmospheric
anomaly that simply resembled a new star
but Tico's careful observations proved
Beyond any shadow of a doubt that this
wasn't the case
almost overnight he tore up 2 000 years
of accepted science
[Music]
these days we know that what Tico saw
back in 1572 wasn't actually a new star
at all it was a Supernova one of the
first ever witnessed by human eyes the
discovery was a turning point in his
life transforming him from a rich Danish
kid with a weird hobby into a
world-renowned astronomer it's also
brought him to the attention of the king
of Denmark Frederick II he was so
impressed he made Tico lord of the
island of Ven and all who lived there
over the ensuing years this small Speck
of land between Denmark and Sweden
evolved into the epicenter of a
Celestial Revolution ultimately
reshaping our understanding of the
universe the then Observatory one of the
first in history to be entirely state
funded cost one percent of the entire
budget of Denmark making it pound for
pound one of the most expensive
scientific institutions ever built
but this wasn't an observatory like
anything we would recognize today the
first stone was laid in 1576 more than
30 years before the invention of the
telescope all observations recorded at
the observatory were made with the naked
eye and the help of esoteric instruments
like quadrants sextants paralytic rulers
astronomical clocks and armillary
spheres Tico lived and worked on then
revolutionizing almost every aspect of
astronomy redefining methods of
observation and dramatically improving
existing equipment as a result his
measurements were on average more than
10 times more accurate than those that
have come before at his best Tico came
within half an arc minute of a star's
true position that's one 120th of the
degree and it wasn't just the accuracy
of his measurements that was so special
it was the volume in his lifetime he
significantly improved almost every
known astronomical record but there was
more to life on then than stars and
sextants Tico is dedicated to his
science but the years had done nothing
to tame his more Outland of Tendencies
it was around this time he came into
possession of his pet moose which lived
on the island and followed him around
like a puppy even indoors
the remarkable Observatory on Van
attracted important people from all over
the world from scientists to Kings
Antico through lavish parties to welcome
them
as entertainment he hired a clairvoyant
dwarf called Jeb he would hide under the
table during feasts occasionally jumping
out to tell some random Danish Lord that
he was about to die a horrible death or
inherit a fortune
history has forgotten what happens to
Jep the magic dwarf but sadly we do know
the fate of the Moose it grew so popular
that Tico began sending it out to
parties as a kind of diplomatic Envoy
it was at one of these engagements that
the poor creature was plied with so much
beer it fell down a set of stairs and
died Tico was understandably not a moose
Tico's time at the top came to an abrupt
end with the death of Frederick II in
1588 the King's son and successor
Christian IV was to put it mildly not
Tico's biggest fan and neither were many
members of his court
not only did the greatest astronomer
have a reputation for being a truly
crappy Lord who treated his subjects on
then like little modern slaves rampant
rumors also implicated tico in an affair
with Christian's mother the former Queen
Sophie
by this point Tico had also become a
little too big for his boots demanding
huge sums of money to fuel both his
research and his hedonistic lifestyle
with King Christian in commands the
state's Financial faucet was firmly shut
and mounting political pressure
compelled Tico to depart Denmark for
good
he traveled through much of Europe
before finally settling in Prague where
he became Royal astronomer under the
patronage of Rudolph the second Holy
Roman Emperor
[Music]
by this point in his life most of Tico's
most important work was already behind
him but he still had time to make one
last absolutely gigantic contribution to
science it was common knowledge that his
astronomical data was by far the most
accurate in the world and that made it
highly sought after by a new generation
of young astronomers amongst them was a
28 year old German by the name of
Johannes Kaplan
Kepler wrote to Tico asking for access
to his Star Charts batika refused
instead offering to employ the young man
as his assistant the rest as they say is
history
today Kepler is rightly regarded as one
of the most important scientists of all
time but his most famous achievement the
three laws of planetary motion would
simply not have been possible without
the unprecedented accuracy of his
mentors measurements
half a century later Isaac Newton would
build on Kepler's work when coming up
with his own laws of motion that today
formed the basis of classical mechanics
Tico died in 1601 and even that he
performed with Panache it all started as
so many things did with a feast
according to Kepler Tico had been
drinking heavily no surprise there and
the sheer volume of alcohol was
beginning to take its toll on the Aging
astronomer's bladder but court etiquette
dictated that getting up in the middle
of a feast was bad manners and so Tico
ignored this most pressing call of
nature
arriving home that night his beleaguered
bladder had gone on strike refusing to
pass a single Pico liter of piss his
condition deteriorated rapidly and 11
very painful days later he was dead
the general consensus is that he died of
a ruptured bladder but not everyone
agreed with that conclusion in 1901 on
the 300th anniversary of his death
Tico's body was exhumed so that his
final resting place could be restored
but a few scraps of his remains never
made it back into the ground
90 years later a Swedish research team
found elevated levels of mercury in
hairs from his mustache
it was an intriguing Discovery because
ever since Tico's death there had been
rumors that he may have been murdered
even more interesting is the fact that
Tico suffered with insomnia fever and
delirium in the days leading up to his
death all symptoms of mercury poisoning
as for whodunits the two main suspects
are an agent of Christian IV or possibly
Johannes Kepler and there are clear
motives on both sides
we already know the king wasn't Tico's
biggest fan for the whole he slept with
my mum thing but it may have gone even
deeper than that
in a Twist of Star Wars proportions some
historians have speculated that
Christian might have been a product of
the affair in other words Darth Tico was
his father
if true that would have made Christian
illegitimate and therefore not actually
the rightful king of Denmark at all and
it isn't hard to see why he desired such
information to be dead and buried
as for Kepler he had at times a volatile
relationship with his mentor Tico proved
extremely reluctant to share most of his
precious astronomical data particularly
the observations of Mars that were to
prove so crucial to Kepler's research
it wasn't until Tico's death that Kepler
finally got his hands on them
so is there any truth to these theories
well no probably not further analysis of
the hair samples in 2010 found that the
mercury levels were within the normal
range and that no other poisons were
present that doesn't mean Tico wasn't
murdered but there's no real evidence to
support it in truth Tico's life was so
remarkable it doesn't need to end with a
murderous twist to be worthy of
remembering this is a man who almost
single-handedly laid the foundations of
modern astronomy refuted widely held
scientific fallacies that had
perpetuated for thousands of years and
paved their way for men like Kepler and
Newton to change our understanding of
the universe forever whether he was
murdered by Kepler or by his own bladder
it doesn't really matter
if you're into stargazing yourself
you've probably noticed that the Moon is
Puck marked with craters according to
the latest count there are well over a
million with a diameter of over a
kilometer most are fairly nondescript
but a few do stand out one of these can
be found in the southern lunar Highlands
at 80 miles across it's pretty bloody
big but what's really special about this
particular crater Tico's crater to give
it its official name is that we can
still see the spectacular spray of
material that was ejected when it Formed
these bright white rays are over 2 000
kilometers long and can clearly be seen
with the naked eye from Earth making
them one of the most prominent features
of the entire Moon
considering everything Tico taught us
about the heavens it's fitting that
that's where we choose to honor him so
next time you're out for an evening
stroll at full moon be sure to look up
and remember Tico brahe the beer
drinking moose owning astronomical
explorer who single-handedly rewrote the
celestial map
foreign
thanks for watching